this is the best time to be born in the
history of the planet
and uh if you want to talk about dental
work you want to talk about vision care
you want to talk about
opportunities to raise a family and to
get an education
[Music]
[Applause]
bing heckman thank you for being on 20
minute leaders how are you
terrific now you think times interesting
times but but you seem to be in the mo
in one of the nicest places in the world
where are
what is this background so uh this
actually is um a background that you
might
be more likely to reconcile recognize
this is the back side there's a view so
this is right after you're in this dark
room and you can you see all the faces
and all the names then you go
out to the light and you see the beauty
of israel is that right
yeah right wonderful well bing such a
pleasure to have you
coming from an industry that i really
know nothing about now you
you don't really you deal with real
estate but you don't really deal with
like
you know a small apartment investment
like i hope to
to to be a part of or that you know the
average person deals with but you really
deal with
massive massive real estate uh
considerations
you mentioned a few of them right before
but i'll let you take it away and tell
me a little bit about what what it means
to you
and how you've sort of paved your way
through this and then we can move on to
to some other things that we want to
talk about sure so
i did feasibility studies for projects
for stanford research institute sri
international uh private sector shopping
centers apartment buildings office
buildings industrial
the monterey bay you told me right a
monterey bay aquarium
i love it facilities convention centers
arena stadiums uh
performing arts centers uh recreational
facilities calgary
um you know different places uh fort
dodge iowa
uh a wide span you go into a community
you learn all about it and you can kind
of understand it
when you get into a more complex area la
san francisco there's so much that goes
on
it's a little bit hard to see anyway uh
i went from there
mai appraiser um what is the phys
what is the feasibility tester what does
that even mean
so i look at other development i see
what it costs to operate what it costs
to build
what revenues they generate and the
feasibility
is having the revenues generated cover
the cost to build and create a profit so
it's like you're going to build an
apartment building
you know here's what it costs to build
here's the rent you're going to get
and so it doesn't make sense does it not
make sense so when you look for let's
take for example the case study of the
monterey bay so you actually look at
okay what is this actual look what given
the the structure that we want to build
and the prices
how much is this going to cost us and
then you take a look at
the ticket sales and the projections
very simple story i looked at aquaria
all over the country um and i saw what
the staffing was
i saw what the use days were i saw what
the traffic was
wow okay look at the different types of
exhibits that had greater appeal wow i
presented that to david packard and his
daughter julie
who was a marine biologist with the
hobden
marine science center next door and they
looked and they said that's all fine but
we're going to go big
and so here's an idea of what you're
going to get into and then here's what
they decide to do
which is a wonderful thing so art we
gave them a foundation base of the
general expectation
and you know obviously they're pretty
capable and understanding insightful
and so then they chose to do what they
they did which was terrific
wow that's incredible setting you know
clearly anchors a tourism area
you know um made famous
so it's not just real estate it's really
it's hardcore economics work to really
understand all of the moving pieces
and and whether this is an economically
uh viable opportunity
that's right you look at what what goes
on elsewhere
you understand that you see how it
applies
um and you know what kind of you know in
other types of properties what kind of
market share
in this one you know it's like what kind
of tourism is there and how will that
feed in
um so it's that kind of thing so i have
to ask when you deal with the
projects that are you know tens or
hundreds of millions of dollars
and how granular do you get in terms of
the
you know the estimate so for example in
this case how
i mean how exact do you try to be in
estimating the potential revenue
it's like an appraisal uh again after
sri
i became an appraiser after becoming an
appraiser i worked for a high net worth
individual
and bought office institutional quality
opportunistic investments in the western
states so office
r d industrial properties and in each
case just like an appraisal
you're looking at the revenues expenses
and the returns
and in acquisitions you're looking you
know what are the risk issues i would
find properties with a
lease expiration in three years it was
too small for institutions too big for
private
my guy it was perfect he has 40 of these
you know a couple of them roll out it's
fine anybody else if they only have one
you know they can't handle it so you
find a strategy that works a unique uh
niche and each case is there's a real
world
operation that's similar and so you're
comparing it to those
to find you know what
the value would be what the opportunity
would be um
and in terms of granularity you know
appraisals you know they try to get to
be
90 accurate in their values 95
and there's you know a lot of variation
a lot of subjectivity think about
go look at a stock analyst on on any big
company
you're going to see a range of opinions
that
uh is stunningly broad
and that's all subjective and they have
extensive information
to draw from but you know you have a
variety of opinions and so
with anything that factor is in there
but you hope to
uh you know get repeat business so you
try to be reasonably on
on top of things wonderful so you so you
work for you work for this individual
and then you move on and then you
mentioned
mia right the uh member of appraisal
institute mai
mai after sri before acquisitions
lots of abbreviations it gets
complicated yeah now
now i'm working with colliers as a real
estate broker
i do investment sales and i do help
tenants i like
helping tenants they need to help other
the landlords have all the information
tenants are struggling to survive
the rents are very high and we try to
you know uh uh even you know the level
the playing field a little bit
definitely okay so being an expert in
economics talk to me a little bit about
what's happening now because
you know coming in at 24 and just
starting out my my
sort of my economic life and this is a
pretty interesting time
give me a little bit of context about
backing it up that
you know people have been saying how
awful things are
and they've been saying that for a
period of years this is the best time to
be born in the history of the planet
and if you want to talk about dental
work you want to talk about vision care
you want to talk about
opportunities to raise a family and to
get an education
right now we have an unbelievably unique
time
and but we started out with a healthy
market
what people don't understand is there's
two and only two
drivers of long-term gdp growth and gdp
isn't everything but
it's a central metric and those two
drivers are
labor force growth and productivity so
when somebody tells you they're gonna
grow the economy at four percent
they essentially have no understanding
of economics
short term tax cut spending whatever you
can blip it
long term you have to have those two
elements
and if you do you'll have and again one
percent per year
uh productivity one percent per year
labor force two percent
is a healthy gdp growth in the current
world we're going to go to ten
billion people we're at seven five
they're gonna shrink
back down according to demographers i'm
not a demographer that's what i hear
but right now we have a good
economic base uh we have a lot of
pent-up demand that's going to express
itself once we get things wrapped up
i don't know what the damage will be
nobody really knows
but we are incredibly fortunate
and and the thing that really strikes me
really strikes me today is the
opportunity we have
to see that we're all in this together
you know i feel like we're in a time
of more intense tribalism than i've ever
felt
yeah i'm not sure why uh you know we
should be advancing
uh from an economic metrics point of
view as i view it we're actually better
off compared to
most of history we all have our thoughts
on the topic
but you know and i also note that a
healthy community is different than
tribalism
but for me right now there's a profound
lack of perspective so i i'd like to
talk about that a bit about 100
all right so let me just share something
on my screen please
because this is um i think um
tells the story can you read that yes i
can
this is by albert einstein i think most
people know who he was
a human being is part of a whole
called by us the universe this is a part
limited in time and space
and he experiences himself or she
thoughts and feelings as separated from
the rest
and it's really kind of an optical
delusion of our consciousness
as einstein puts this this is the kind
of delusions of really a prison force we
see
ourselves as separate and uh
at odds with each other and our task
is to free ourselves from this
prison by widening our circles of
compassion
embrace all living creatures the whole
creation is beauty this
is the central theme of pretty much
every major tradition
that has occurred and this is the
perspective that's lost
we see our little silos we see our
little tribes
we don't see our ethical imperatives
we don't see our connection right and
another great um visionary
abraham joshua heschel when i take the
time to look
there's wonder in the commonplace and
wonder
is commonplace i want to reflect on that
just a little bit
for me the big picture helps put things
in perspective
by which i mean if you took all visible
matter
in the universe big topic seventy
percent
is hydrogen 27 helium 97
is stars the other three percent
only is all the other elements of the
periodic table here we are
are the carbon-based speck of dust to
the goldilocks orbit around a heat
source
on which there was an algae bloom
oxygenating the atmosphere
and we live in an oasis
on which life has spawned in a
incredibly
hostile universe right and we understand
the magnitude of that gift for you and i
to have this conversation
for us to raise a family or to pursue
whatever we might
that is a perspective that i think is
sorely lacking we're disconnected from
nature we're disconnected from
our connectedness right and
uh we're all part of the same and and
we're unique expressions of that but
we're distorted
expressions of that um you know all
great traditions help to reduce our
distortion what do they want it to do
the common team is seeing and feeling
everything and everyone as sacred
can you imagine if we all felt and saw
each other and this oasis
in that light and it's again expanding
our circles of compassion another
thing that's important is to have a
sense of the magnitude of our ignorance
our silos and our echo chambers
40 this is a gallup poll that i've
looked at for
10 years running and it repeats each
year the same outcome
gallup i still don't believe this but
look it up
the percent of adults in america that
believe in creationism
the earth is ten thousand years old
creationism
forty percent in america wow so
we have forty percent of americans
believe that the earth is 10
000 years old yeah and you know
obviously
we've lost our faith in science uh it's
a lot of chaos we're emotional beings
and creatures and uh so what do we do
you know that's a big question well we
start with really looking at our actions
and our interactions with others around
us
a major theme again of all traditions so
i'm going to start with
amos that book of the bible is like 750
bc
so at 2000 that 2800 years ago
they were saying righteousness and
justice
is what's paramount and then you go
like uh to i don't know let's say um
350 bce is when uh plato wrote the
republic which centered
as a theme justice and why is it that
nice guys finished last
why is this why is that but it was also
the the
um great appreciation
of reason uh but we remain emotional
beings but
justice is a central theme
and it's really an ethical imperative
for all major traditions right so what's
happening
let's understand this a little bit i
took a course religious literacy
and people understand violence as direct
violence
but violence is more than that it's
structural violence
and it's cultural violence so what do i
mean by that
if you are suppressing opportunities
you are creating structural violence if
you're vilifying if you're
demeaning you're creating cultural
violence
and uh you know most would be appalled
at direct violence if you had you know
police shown up with police dogs and
fire hoses and
running people down who are peacefully
protesting right that would be
uh appalling but people are not appalled
they're insensitive
to cultural violence and structural
violence
which are just as egregious we need to
better understand how
we contribute individually directly
and indirectly think of the black lives
matter
the southerners use the bible to justify
slavery
and sacred texts
are for revealing and inspiring a sense
of the sacred
to use sacred texts to justify
exploitation
historical claims oppression it's an
egregious
violation of the second commandment one
of the foundations
of humanity's aspirations
there's a very i'm going to repeat that
action sacred texts are for revealing
inspiring a sense of the sacred
to use sacred text to justify
exploration
historical claims or oppression is a
horrific violation of the second
commandment
and you know if we learn nothing from
history
such sacrilege by religious zealots has
been the cause of many wars
and much suffering so what's the lens
that we want to look at i'm going to
quote
he was a jesuit the way we treat people
is the way we treat god very
clear think of trauma
you have you know a an oppressed
situation
there's great trauma in that and that
trauma compounds
if you have opportunity it's like having
a dollar
it grows and invests and it grows over
time
if you don't you have a cycle of poverty
that cannot be broken
vilifying others is cultural violence
condoning and supporting it is too even
if
only to indirectly constraining
opportunities
of others is structural violence
separating others limiting or preventing
exposure and interaction
causes cultural violence to fester
conversely facilitating exposure contact
reduces cultural violence it builds
bridges
we need bridges not walls a quote that
i'm going to
cite is really a beautiful one yeah it's
from kurt
um tucholski a country is not what it
does
it's also what it tolerates and you know
we
we've probably heard micah and there's a
very famous uh
you know uh i guess verse uh
book micah 6-8
he has told you o mortal what is good
and what does the lord require of you
but to do justice love
kindly and walk humbly with your god
and to me um this
perspective connection with nature
connection with
the the being that we're all part of
and seeing each other as a part of that
is
um something we need to move toward
no no and being i completely agree i
would love to ask you a few questions
do you mind stopping the screen share
just so that i can see you again
um and i i think that really um
i'm what i'm what i'm curious about and
i think it's it's extraordinary that
how much thought and and meaning you put
into this what i'd love to know is where
does this all come from so
you know coming from economics working
on really
incredible incredible deals what brings
you to be so passionate about this idea
of our
mutual responsibility to be kind to each
other and and to be part of this
creation
where does it all stem from okay so i
graduated college
a hundred years ago and i had to decide
what what the heck am i gonna do
and so i started thinking okay gosh i
don't know it was back in the 60s
i thoroughly enjoyed the 60s but that's
another story
um but it was a time of reflection and
uh you know did i want to
go into service do i want to do this do
i want to do that
do i want to be a business person um and
i realized that what i need to do to
understand
how to navigate my life is to see what's
important and to me what's important
is this what is the nature of creation
and our role in it and that theme
has been with me through these decades
as a central point to ponder
in all the opportunities that i've had
and i lived in los
angeles and had numerous opportunities
to look at different traditions
i've traveled you know the world uh
india
israel you know wherever uh to look at
centers
um and meet with you know teachers
that i thought were helpful in some way
we have such a cornucopia of resources
it's absolutely extraordinary so
it's basically you know my central
journey the other things i do
certainly are practical i like to refer
to it as practical misses i think that's
where my surprise stems from because you
know a very practical guy i mean there's
economics is one of the most practical
things i think to study unless you're a
theorist but but i think that it's
still extraordinary and i you know we
have just just a few just one minute
left but but i'd love to
ask you my last and favorite question
which is three words that you would best
use to describe yourself
well as i think about it i thoroughly
enjoy looking into things
exploring and so i guess
probably what i'd say is i'm just a
fascinated
explorer i find it fascinating i'm
fascinated by it
and i i can't think of anything more
interesting or exciting
so i'm a fascinated explorer that's
wonderful okay so i'm going to take that
as two words but i think that
they're so grand and so you know they
can mean
every person can interpret them in a
different way that it just alludes to it
to more so so i'll take that
a in front so that's three words you win
it's wonderful bing thank you for the
time and thank you for sharing your
thoughts
on on our mutual responsibility and i
think it's i think it's it's
wonderful to have both you know very
practical and livelihood on one hand but
then
thinking about the about larger picture
things and i and i love that he chose
the background
of the view right out of yad vashem that
with all the symbolics that it has with
it
and you know some of the viewers of this
don't know necessarily about yad vashem
and what
what this represents but but really it
represents life
after you know the the worst possible
place you can come from it's
being and and that you know i i've been
to edwards i'm quite a few times and
and it really it's uh it's an
extraordinary feeling coming out from
this darkness up and seeing this this
beautiful countryside
and i think that our talk also resonates
a lot with this idea of we're in a very
difficult time
but we can always step back and and look
at the look at the the beautiful world
that we live in and what's our
responsibility to maintain it
bing thank you for the inspiration and
hopefully appreciate
with wonder fascination and curiosity i
love it
incredible gift that we have
take care bing thank you very much bye